Here are the solutions were 6 plus or minus the square root of 31. Great work
if you found those two answers. We subtract 5 from both sides of the equation
to get this. Next we identify the b so that way we can complete the square. The
b value is negative 12, which means b over 2 is negative 6. And b over 2
squared is positive 36. We add this amount to both sides of our equations, so
that way we can complete the square. We rewrite the left hand side as x minus 5
squared, and the right hand side as 31. Next, we take the square root of both
sides of the equation to get x minus 6 equals plus or minus the square root of
31. And finally, we add 6 to both sides of the equation to get our final
answers. Here, we can't simplify the square root of 31 since 31 is a prime
number. The only factors of 31 are 31 and 1.